All right. Yes, I'm a smidge late in
reviewing the new RX970 series GPUs from
AMD. In my defense, we didn't get sent
them for review until I had to take a
Fortnite trip to South Africa and Yins
bought all of them at retail. So, I
actually had my 9070 XT order cancelled
by Newegg. But here we are about a month
removed from the launch of these
watershed cards and we did our best to
cover some things in this video that
weren't typically covered at the
original release 30 plus days ago. We
have three different flavors of XT that
we tested. One
nonXT970 comparing it to the latest
Nvidia stuff. And we spent quite a bit
of time playing with overclocking via
power profiles in undervolting. So,
there's a bit more here than what we
would have done if we were rushed to hit
the embargo date for AMD. Not that we
could have since we didn't have them
cards. Additionally, we have the value
of hindsight knowing that the prices AMD
indicated at the March 6th birth did not
hold in the real world. so we can do an
updated price value comparison against
what Nvidia is putting out there. So for
testing, we had our grubby mits on the
Orus Elite, ASRock Tai Chichi, and Steel
Legend 970 XTs. AMD sent us the Orus,
Trick sent us the Taichi for a build,
and we ripped the Steel Legend out of a
Best Buy pre-built because that was the
fastest way for me to buy one before I
knew we were getting the others. And the
9070 that we used in testing was the
Power Color Hell Helm that I personally
bought on Newegg. We stacked all those
up against the se and 7900 XTX from AMD
and then the RTX 5070 and 5080 from
Nvidia. Again, just like our 5070 and
5080 reviews, we don't have access to a
5070 Ti since we did get a scent to
sample and they're a Sabrina Carpenter
concert sold out. to get all the
particulars of the cards out of the way
before we dive into the gaming numbers.
We're just going to be using the Orus
Elite and Hellhound in our comparisons
to the other cards and then I'll get to
the comparisons between each of the XTs
after that and following that the
overclocking undervolting stuff. So,
looking at temps and power draws, the
AMD cards still draw quite a bit of
power but definitely deliver the frames
to back it up. The 9070 was the lowest
out of our testing at 230 W. Then the
5070 at 252. Then the Seven00 GRE at
265, followed by the 9070 XT at 340. The
5080 hit 343. And then the 7900 XTX was
the hungriest juice sucker at 347 watts
under gaming load. But they all didn't
appear to be thermally constrained at
all. The 9070 XT and 5080 ran at about
55C during the Sweat Sessions Marvel
Rivals, while the rest of the lineup was
close to 65C. nothing to really
constrain the GPUs even with the XTX's
blower style card. Now, using our 10
game testing suite that includes a mix
of AAA graphical heavy hitters and some
lighter esports titles, we find that the
order changes up quite a bit from the
power draw list. Using the 9070 as the
baseline GPU, we see that it beats the
7900 GRE by about 19%, which is right
around what AMD claimed. Then it's about
4% faster than the same priced Nvidia
5070. It's 10.5% slower than the seen
XTX, 17% slower than its XT big brother,
and 37% slower than the RTX 5080. But
while the 5080 looks like it's massively
above all the other cards, I got to take
a moment to just sit right here and tell
you how the charts got wonked out by one
game. It's no secret that certain games
tend to perform better on AMD or Nvidia
depending on the game engine and game
developer. And there's one game in our
lineup that is just so preferential to
Nvidia cards that it heavily skews our
overall comparisons. In games like
Monster Hunter Wilds, there's barely a
1% difference between the 9070 XT and
the RTX 5080. They trade blows in
Horizon Forbidden West as well. Even in
Cyberpunk, without rate tracing, these
two heavily price separated cards go
toe-to-toe. The game that violates our
standard deviation curve happens to be
Blackmith Wukong with there being a 37%
gap between those two cards, which makes
sense if you only look at price and not
how the 970 XT holds up in nearly every
other title. Maybe this will get
resolved with future driver updates or
maybe the gap will stay there. But we
also want to give you comparisons just
dropping the Monkey game from the list
even if I love it so much. Seriously, it
is a fun game, not just a good GPU
benchmark. I beat it. Got the secret
ending. It was fantastic. Anywh who, I'm
going to get back to the data. Removing
the Monkey King, the chart changes a
scoochi. The 9070 beats the GRE by 21%.
The 5070 by almost 8%. It loses to the
XTX by a larger 12.4%, the XT970 by 17%,
and then the 5080 only pops up to be 33%
faster. Now, changing it up to use the
9070 XT as the baseline card with the
monkey game. It beats all the competing
cards except for the 5080, which is a
17% winner. Vanishing Stone Wukong
narrows the gap between the 5080 and the
XT to just 14%. It's clear the 5080 is
the faster card, but at a major cost.
Looking at actual street prices, the AMP
5080 we used is 90% more expensive than
the Orus Elite XT. Presuming MSRP
though, the 5080 should only be 66%
pricier than AMD's newest flagship. But
still, that's a lot of D'ach for less
than 20% performance gain and no
increase in VRAM. 16 gig half,000 card
that the 5080 regrettably is. Speaking
of value though, here's the rest of the
price to performance lineup for the
cards as tested at actual market prices.
And then here's that same chart if we
assume you can somehow find these cards
at their regular old MSRPs. Breaking
things down with the going prices for
these GPUs on the open market is rough.
Most of the cards are going for hundreds
of bucks more than their supposed real
price. Our dollar per frame for 1440p
native performance makes the 9070 XT
Steel Legend the best bang for buck at
MSRP. But considering street prices, the
Hellhound's actually the better deal.
Looking at 4K performance, the best
option for maximizing your cash is in
the real world market the 9070
Hellhound, but you are getting slightly
lower 4K performance by going with the
nonXT card. If you go with any of the
other higherend cards, then the Orus
Elite and Steel Legend cards end up
being close to the same value with 9.2
and $9.3 per frame, respectively. At
MSRP though, the 9070 Hellhound and 9070
XT Steel Legend are similarly close
being only $.1.1 off per frame. So, it's
incredibly clear that AMD has a winner
on their hands with this latest RDNA4
generation. They stack up no problem
against Nvidia's competition and outpace
the generation before healthfully. If
you can get either the 9070 or 9070 XT
at a fair and reasonable price, they'll
absolutely give you a great gaming
experience. The XT is the better value
card overall, considering its top tier
level performance. But getting the 9070
barebones wouldn't put you too far
behind, though. But now, let's shift our
attention to the three different 9070 XT
cards and see if there's any value in
picking up an overclocked expensive
model or sticking to an MSRP card. The
Orus Elite is the most expensive of our
bunch at $759. The ASRock Taichi is $729
and the ASRock Steel Legend was
$599 at launch, but has since bumped
itself up to $669, an 11% price jump. I
will also take this moment to say that
Newegg has the price at $670. MicroEnter
still has it in MSRP, but it doesn't pop
up in search results, only if you have a
direct link to it. It's a real weird
situation. They're not in stock anyways.
670 is the presumed price here. Now,
there are differences between these
cards. The MSRP cards are rated to run
at 304 watts, which the Steel Legend
does, but the Taichi and Orus cards have
an 11% higher power draw, coming in at
340 watts of total board power. The
temps on the cards though were slightly
different than their wattages indicate.
The Steel Legend actually ran the
hottest, coming close to 60C in gaming.
The Orus Elite was closer to 55C and
then the Tai Chi was the best cooled of
the bunch at just 50C in the middle of
graphical output. And the performance
gap is related to pricing. The priciest
Orisel is the top framer with a 90 FPS
average in all of our testing. The Tai
Chi drops only 2 FPS to average 88. And
then the Steel Legend was only 5 FPS off
coming in at 85. So, you get 94% of the
total performance of the most wallet
draining card for just 88% of the price.
78% if the Steel Legend drops back to
MSRP. So, really, this can be summarized
to say spend as little money as you can
on a 9070 XT while getting the card look
that you want. It's an obvious
statement, but we wanted to reassure you
that you're not missing out a ton by
going with the lower priced MSRP models
that have lower power targets. 11%
higher draw for 6% better performance on
these guys. The value is in the 9070 XT,
not the variants. But speaking of power
and performance changes, let's now get
to the overclocking section of this
presentation. As demonstrated in many
previous generations of AMD cards, the
best way to get more frames out of your
Radeon GPU is to undervolt it rather
than try to jam it full of as much
electrical pressure as possible.
Durbower had a great video where he got
a ton of extra performance out of his
Red Devil limited edition card, but we
didn't quite have the same headroom on
any of our XTs with getting the voltage
as low as it would go while still being
perfectly stable for everyday use and
cranking the power limit up as much as
we were allowed, which was only 10%. We
saw a whopping total of 3% better
performance. It's nowhere near what
others have gotten, but it was
consistent across all three variants of
these RDNA4 cards. Maybe AMD will give
us more access to tinkering with the
inards to squeeze out more performance,
but it wasn't anywhere near enough to
put the XT in 5080 territory besides the
couple of games where there was already
a 1% gap. But as we showed in our RTX
5080 review, which you can check out
right up there, those are capable of
boosting another 7 to 10% as well. So,
if you tweak the XT, the 5080s tweaking
puts it even further beyond. But the
brass tax at the end of the day is wow.
AMD created a killer set of GPUs this
generation. The 9070 and 9070 XT
exceeded every expectation that I had
for them prior to launch when we were
just hearing rumors of what they
couldn't. They slap Nvidia's similarly
priced 5070 so hard that it was
completely dead on arrival and a bad
value if you just care about pure gaming
performance. They get reasonably close
to the 16 gig limited 5080 while costing
significantly less even with horrible
MSRP practices by AMD as well. And they
overall seem like a no-brainer choice if
you're looking for a solid gaming GPU
and you don't want to spend a grand on a
card. That's something that I couldn't
say about the 7000 series cards. They
were a good value, but a 4080 Super
versus a 7900 XDX was a closer tossup
than what we have here today. Obviously,
Nvidia has other intangibles such as
their DLSS4 tech, multiframe AI
generation, massive media encoders on
the 50 series, and CUDA acceleration,
which can sway people to get the worst
value team. But it would only be worse
for gaming. If you're just a pure and
true gamer with no business use cases or
content creation, I see no reason not to
go AMD this generation.